all right so we'll to finish actually
the previous part we said that we'll
have this Carana just just to show just
the pawn structure and Bishops and I
actually think that we are even getting
very similar opening very very similar
very very similar
Tada exactly
okay let let's just not looking at
opening at all just wanted to prove some
positional
idea uhhuh giving the
pawn and
now might B6 so taking this
one
G5 not bad one I remember analyzing it
and thinking okay well I was doing
actually commentary on ICC that day and
we thought C5 or G5 and G5 we actually
liked a bit less cuz Knight E4 is best
move and white maybe better but Anand
went just very passive and then just got
into immediately worse end
game it's okay he he lost this dis
position he's just suffering here but
the point was whether it is C5 or G5
same idea you just want to get more
actually G5 is playing on the dark SRS
with the pawn with the idea to attack C5
might be more positional approach but
very very similar to what we had before
only that in tomaseski kamsky if White
had done nothing he could have gotten
after Knight H5 just the demonstration
could have gotten the same Bishop
without even been paying a pa
okay so what today so we had all this
big drama and tomaseski and Kamura is
out and kamsky is out and then we have
this dude
vashir that Ben was you
know uh supporting him with his soul
with everything he has actually since
round one so he's a True Believer and
Bash this Bashir yesterday defended or
well CR didn't win a completely
winnable
position but maybe not not a very very
easy one maybe we can have a quick one
just to see the position they had
yesterday the interesting part is that
while looking at the game I remembered
at least three games that Kik had
similar stories similar type of end
games it's a it's interesting when you
know let's let's let's go very quickly
to the critical position that we want to
go very quickly so
actually I don't think that there is a
function to just Skip and since the game
was 125 moves and I just want to jump
into move 55 so this will be the fastest
way okay bottom line after long
game K got the maximum he could actually
which is a PA out all pawns on one
side of course if there are no knights
we immediately go home it's just
immediate draw I mean no not not much to
to see here but there are two pair of
fruits what what does two pair of fruits
right now give some possibilities even
to go after the king tiny
bit black king is weaker than white now
looking at this position again I'm going
fast fast fast okay they exchange one
pair of Hook niik had amazingly similar
end game against against cenov in
2003 if I'm not mistaken in vacan 10
years 10 and a bit years amazingly
similar end game which I think there it
was a bit a bit more in White's favor
the pawns were immediately more advanced
and he actually ended up checkmating or
winning the game then kamik had an end
game again if I'm not mistaken Two
Against One but with some weakness
against
ianov 2008 or
nine which he also won so very
interesting and we're very soon
approaching the most interesting end
game out there okay I'm moving it just
too fast cuz this is not our
topic okay making some improvement yeah
this actually allowing this check was
not not really that okay and now
computers say black is still okay after
Knight D6 I think it was only move so in
some versions he can block but I heard
cic in the analysis already saying okay
you know it's
already black has to be really careful
and he should really calculate a lot
already achievement for white if black
has to be
careful yeah the thing is that here
still
okay but now this is absolutely a
horrible move first of all if King F2
that's important to touch this point
take and this is a draw
because what they said I mean if
something like this then I think just
exchanging just exchanging the pawn is
going to be a draw right can we exchange
the pawn here immediately yes we can
here I give check
and just go
here right this will be okay no
problem and if making some effort like
this then this is
just
sorry then just something like this even
if the king gets to this Square let's
say the king somehow get to this Square
you just you just put a knight let let
me show the
position this is just a for
and whenever it goes here here the only
way to attack it is for the king to make
all this journey but some some somewhere
on the road there will be a G6
exchanging the pawn so okay it seems all
complicated for us but kind of you just
know the end game not that complicated
but here vashir play this horrible move
Rook
F1 what's the problem that now he's well
one problem he's just losing here
because after Knight D6 look where he
put his
Rook the worst part the king F7 and it
will be captured I mean The Rook was
other Square yes maybe unpleasant but
still most likely in a dsh
territory put the Rook on F1 just
horrible
thing G6 and here kamik said he was
thinking about taking and playing Rook
B7 which looks kind of
winning here
this no okay they they they pointed out
some some lines but to me it just looks
like kind of kind of just winning I mean
actually I'm not certain why he didn't
play that
way I mean this Rook Rook here is a
really really strong oh and also this
line important here here and if this
move Knight F4 and after take there is
this
way that's that's just an important
let's see the entire line that kown Nick
mentioned this this and now this move
very important and the pawn cannot be
captured because of King F4 and white
ends up winning after all this big
beautiful drama big line but
winning but okay actually this is not
what I even wanted to go to I wanted to
show you this
position does someone remember similar
end game to that in comic history
when I've seen the when I've seen this
game I remember the three end games
against cenov against Elan of nobody
mention it and another quite famous end
game by Kik with even more famous
opponent you remember Jacob only because
mentioned it in the interview oh yeah oh
Kik mentioned it I haven't seen that he
mentioned that that he's like oh my gosh
how could I do it again like the end
game with Kasparov I cannot believe it
okay something yeah coming I think I
think I think in game four in their
match I'm not certain if game four or
six I think G don't really know maybe
game six in the match he had an Pawn on
a
pawn and the Knight was defending it
from the back but kind of very annoying
because the Rook is defending the Knight
The Rook defending the Knight the Knight
defending the pawn and there is no way
to untangle it which apparently he had
to wait 13 years to get exactly the same
situation it's not so simple you know
both players were were saying okay they
thought it's winning but then vashir
said okay completely blacked out and
then when he was looking at his position
suddenly he couldn't find any win
here that's that's that's quite amazing
there's and short was also saying like
Okay well how to win here because what
what does what does black want to do
here if it's black turn here I play this
beautiful move black is going to play
this
move and then the Knight is is going to
be is under attack Knight goes take draw
that's that's that's the problem the
Knight is on the other side on f8 not on
F4 I mean there's nothing to look with
the rook and Knight but not that the
Knight is on that side of the
board so there was only one way to win
here and I short in the official
analysis room also said oh my gosh what
to play here he couldn't know not easy
and then you have two of the world best
players not that easy there's only one
way and it is this
way again rook and the Knight is quite
easy
draw how to defend the pawn and now one
tiny
move yeah because Knight F6 we just take
it right but King
E4 does the this thing kicks The Rook
from its optimal Square optimal Square
doing what covering Knight F6 check or
Knight F6 to protect the Rook and it was
amazing that even after the game even in
the analysis the player still didn't see
that I mean this move King E4 was really
hard on them I mean okay they play for
they're playing for two and a half weeks
they're it was five and a half hours
game and all the nerves and stress of
course they are best players in the
world but just sometimes interesting
nice to see that they're still
human
because he didn't see that so what
happened he played this move but now
check check check check
check
okay how to defend the
pawn and here you get that position The
Rook cannot move anywhere defending the
Knight the Knight cannot move anywhere
defending the pawn just let's prevent
the king from participating somehow in
the
game that's it the king forever is going
to be cut on the fourth rank The Rook
defending the Knight that's it
absolutely that's
it well they just played for another 50
and a bit moves
but oh yeah just tiny funny right
stalemate yeah and this is just a draw
so this is the introduction so we have a
she that somehow you know not easy to
kill him you know was playing surviving
here and playing today against Kik
the first rapid and you
know it's interesting we'll take black
side it's interesting
because you know there is a time to play
Bad
Games time to play your worst game of
the
year it shouldn't be in the semifinal
the rapid of the World Cup that's
exactly what happened to vasher I mean
he played he had a great year I mean he
raised his rating I think he started
around 27 00 maybe tiny above is's now
2740 and a bit made it constantly
improving playing at highest level
winning blit and this is really a
killer ah but this game that was a wrong
moment to play your worst game of the
year so he's
white playing against the
scotch and of course this is kik's main
move main main main move move he had
many games Bishop C5 is just another
very main move in
general and Bishop B before was played
it's a kind of kind of interesting idea
I haven't seen this idea up until few
years
ago but it's an interesting idea if
Knight F6 then sorry Knight C3 then
Knight F6 we go to D variation which is
just a normal one for black and
considered absolutely
okay
the normal way is that after Knight F6
white captures capture
E5 attacking the Knight black is
spinning the pawn and this is very
complicated line there were actually
some games even in the tournament by
Carana player number four five in the
world by rating or top
10 but what what's the purpose of this
bishop B4 I mean what what's the idea
behind
it
you don't want a knight to come to his
best sell that is correct basically
wasting this tempy but the Knight is
deprived of C3
square and here yeah Jacob said uh I was
doing he heard me today tiny bit doing
commentary on IC in the morning I didn't
like this move so much it's probably not
a bad one but Queen G4 was played by
Kasparov and is one decent move to look
probably the main move and there were
actually quite a lot of games in the
world rapid championship in June
2013 and the BL one involving Knight
F5 this is how they all
play okay something like this because
actually black has D5 some sacrifice in
the center very powerful idea white
plays C C4 there were some games of
Onana I think sisana some some some
really decent players were playing it my
feeling I think white is a bit
better I mean if you take this bishop
and put it on G7 okay we'll take black
thousand times and a bit more you know
if just black can get all those dark
squares that are so ridiculously weak
right all the dark squares incredible
but black has the other color Bishop I
think white is is a bit better here and
and I'm not certain exactly how better
to play I was actually looking at this
line today quite a bit so really
interesting you know vashir by the way
has been playing more D4
lately maybe he wanted to play E4 and uh
Def and the scotch surprising karnik
probably surprised himself a bit more no
and then that's kind of pity because he
was really like he beat Karana he he had
some decent
games so by any standards how can black
be suffering here here here just D6 next
if take
take that's not take that's a bit
better yeah how can black be suffering
here he's
not but maybe he should have gone
already this way because very soon he's
starting to get a worse position here I
mean actually not yet to be honest this
is all
reasonable but it's clear black is not
suffering and queen H4
okay already we can see some action
around the side of the
board Rook E1 is logical actually
another logical move I think was Knight
E4 just bringing some pieces to this
side yeah and here very soon the game
went out of control for
vashir I mean we said before when we
were discussing the rapid game by
andrein vashir is is same same style
very very strong player actually been
playing really decent chest you know we
see his rating this was his latest
rating before the tournament he he go he
gained like 20 25 more points he he is
in you know he's number 15 I don't know
20 there 15 20 in the world but just
constantly
improving and he's very young like 22
three I don't know 20 and a bit but in
Rapid and
Blitz if there was a blit I I think he
might be even favorite on on KCK oh my
fellow commentator from the day Ben draw
draw no not Ben no I was doing today
analysis with grandmas fold that is
texting while we are doing well
something
important okay nothing important okay
about texting this position to vashir
prepare better next time you play the
semifinal of the World Cup I I talked to
him today and he said they're not
playing he doesn't play first thir they
don't play anymore he doesn't play What
They're not playing a third place game
they're not playing a third place no all
said seriously yeah you really spoke to
him so cool so but but it's amazing
because it's written that there are they
have a tie break for third and fourth
spot now no he told me he's not playing
anymore maybe he doesn't want to play
all
right so yeah because actually it's not
important last time the third one got a
invitation to candidates not this one
yeah and here this Rook E4 was a very
questionable moment right I mean both me
and Ben didn't like this 94 seems right
just reasonable like bringing some
pieces around there just seems very
healthy and we looked at this line okay
maybe H3 possible but just this was a
cool
line and now we have the C5 that's just
just enough right just enough to
actually is it
enough okay if Queen take then
take kind of crazy right
Ben but what if Knight take and then
this move okay we have to juggle
everything take Knight D3 and defending
the Rook attacking the queen mighty
knight and the bishop will come
back how many blunders have I made in
two minutes Ben many or not
so
e in no no no but it's right to play you
want to play Rook e Rook E4 no after oh
93 yeah yeah
93 yeah
no because if not not simple I mean this
is no joke right I mean this is no joke
but okay take a knight
D3 yeah Knight E4 was a important move
but is this position already really bad
I'm not certain I mean okay what is the
threat here for for black first of all
what's the threat
here
simple threat
no Bishop F5 actually yeah Bishop F5
immediately would work but maybe take on
D3 and then Bishop F5 because for
example okay let's say why play this
actually you will be better but not
winning I think I can go here here here
here you have pair of Bishops you are
better but I have this Rook Rook takes
E5 that saved saved white because if you
take on E5 is going to take on F5 but
you're all right with the idea just
Knight take
D3 and Bishop F5 seem kind of
winning Bishop E2 but that's a problem I
mean he just collapsed here immediately
and again the time is no joke when super
fast players starting to
think yeah Queen
G6 yeah and here quite quite absurd I
mean okay you know again me and Ben we
were looking today and I think I just
mentioned oh Rook H4 just losing to
Bishop C2 and the bishop on F3 it's like
just Blitz idea and vashir that I think
he won the European Blitz Championship
with like 19 out of 22 some ridiculous
they played a double round 11 a double
game 11 rounds like ridiculous score I
mean for him to blunder this thing
is I meanook
four the position is
bad but okay maybe it's going to leave
tiny bit tiny bit
longer but yeah because because this is
the idea if we play here and now
thinking about winning the
exchange they just a lot a lot of
captures
but okay why get a big Pawn here and
then some Outpost white is okay here or
at least surviving
lots of captures no white is white is
miserable you know I mean of course he's
playing to defend not to lose
but that's incredible just how he
Blended here Rook
H4 huh Bishop
C2 so what is this idea with Queen take
C2 I mean this is not working for
thousand different reasons
but it just like nothing would work
right
yeah I mean kamik played Knight Tak F3
and the game was just immediately
immediately over check and then take the
queen but but what was his idea his idea
was that you take he wants to play this
move attacking the queen and then having
a
Perpetual kind of cool idea the amazing
thing is that nothing nothing is working
because Queen take take here go whatever
you know let's go to E4 and
only a rook down for only a rook down so
basically you know no like I said coming
with your worst game of the year to the
semifinal or you know the rapid in the
semifinal not very cool not very cool so
to beatnik with uh to beat kamnik with
black
pieces not that easy I I said today on
air that's actually amazing in Rapid
games in Rapid games Kasparov beat him
several I think Kasparov beat him
several times in Rapid CR but how many
normal time control games he beat him
with
black how many games Kasparov right not
a bad player how many games in normal
time control he beat kramnik when
kramnik was white and Kasparov
black Zer it's easy zero yeah Kik didn't
lose one game with white to Kasparov and
they played for since 92 9993 first time
until 2004 five they played probably
many tens of games all the lares and
bacan z and this and their match in the
match he didn't lose also with black so
not really that bad but yeah amazing he
didn't actually Anand Anand has done it
several times that's why in 2008 the
match that Anand won games three and
five he just beat him in the Maran and
that was a huge shock think about it you
never lose one game in your career to
Kasparov with white pieces and you lose
two games in a row with white in a match
that match was over after this so bottom
line he most likely not going to lose to
vashir in the rapid indeed it was a draw
and cnick qualified the other one was
maybe a bit more tight more interesting
because it
involved each one of those
players is going to be it's going to be
like a huge surprise in the candidate
like they are not the caliber of the
world top 10 at least not yet I mean
andrein is actually really young he
might get there tomaseski I kind of
doubt it I mean I think this was the
best best Tournament of his life best
result will be I mean I think he won
European Championship once like 2009 10
something like that maybe right around
it uh obviously very very strong player
but you know very strong player is not
enough to be top 10 in the world but
Andre Ken we'll see
so he's he's on his way to the
candidate and actually playing not like
the game against Sidler where he played
I just want to move the pieces he's
playing your main line of the slav with
the white pieces A6 C5 and this is
actually a line
I at some point I kind of liked it for
white now I think no not one of the most
interesting one and you know this was
really interesting because just amazing
I I I'm not certain how to explain it we
mentioned andrein is one of the world's
fastest players by far fastest and good
player right not just
fast what is this thinking for six
minutes here this is not mistake he
thought for six
minutes and then another one
minute and another 2 minutes there are
some ideas with Knight H4 you know Timor
my friend Timor G which is very very
strong Grandmaster almost 2700 and we
were he was a student of mine in the
University I was teaching and we still
friends and do chess he played a great
game in one of the college events
against grandmas Leon critz very strong
Grandmaster and it was very similar line
with Knight H4 Bishop E6 it involved the
pawn sacrifice and he won very
classically when I come to think about
what Andre kin was thinking no this is
insane say he's 9 minutes down move 10
and nothing happened he could he could
have played the last three moves in 3
seconds Queen B3 H3 Bishop E2 and
nothing and nobody would blink it took 9
minutes my feeling is he was constantly
looking at Knight H4 idea that's why I
mentioned this but really amazing
because don't know don't know what to
say but here we are
94 what's the idea of 94 if you are
like what is that beautiful
idea I don't to
play5
E5 at some point but I would just say
this let's ask a question who is more
space white or black
here white so does it make sense for
black to exchange pieces that's it so
you know that's it you have less space
you want to exchange pieces what does
space means you have X amount of pieces
for y amount of squares if you have half
X well now you have much more spaces per
reality right and you have 20 squares
and you have five pieces okay each piece
get four squares you have four pieces
each piece get five squares so if you
have less space the logic says Okay I
want to exchange pieces it will help me
get rid of the problem so
94 Rook C1 Rook E8 E5 idea take
take I guess if this move this is
something to
consider just an
idea I mean may maybe we can be fancy no
I'm just thinking here here take and if
take maybe I can First Take
here just I think kind of good
idea okay similar
Direction Take take take
take okay very very look very
equal here actually I thought was a very
good moment in the
game the almost automatic move to think
about here will be if you're black which
move almost automatic to think at least
I thought almost
automatic
H5 kind of putting all the
pawns on light squares super solid this
would be correct and guaranteed draw
if the queen side would have been locked
but the queen side is not locked White's
plan is very simple white will play
Queen White will attack C6 with
everything he has very slowly maybe it's
not enough maybe it
is there is one player that is playing
here one one white that can play on this
side hypothetically you know let let
let's just play this move of course it's
a horrible move because of unpas sign C6
is ridiculously weak but let's
hypothetically put this
position oh this is where you shake
hands and go home everyone's happy or
maybe not but no no breaks in the
position everyone super solid and so on
but it wasn't exactly the position and
that's why I remember you know I thought
that H5 which look so automatic is
actually
wrong this is is excellent play by black
excellent
because he managed to undermine weaken
white dark squares the pawns he creat
some
targets and here we thought black is
totally totally okay I mean D4 is weak I
mean black got is think about the
position we just shown a minute ago as
opposed to this one well before White
had the free Woll B4 B5 now he
constantly looking at this
point Queen G6 good move I mean black
black is the one that can be better
here this is where white weakness is and
where black base Pawn base this one oh
yeah go attack this one that's not not
that
easy okay and can just defended he
doesn't want to fix the pawn structure
A5 I'm not certain exactly why I need to
play A5 but
yeah and here here is where
andrein sorry tomaseski started to get
in big trouble I mean he could have just
exchanged actually we were even thinking
about this move well what would you play
with white after this
move
takes and queen H3 I will take your King
on
G2 I'll take with the pawn no I will
take on G4 and then after Queen H3 I
will take the
king no that's what I want to take by
the way but this is something important
because I've seen it especially with
younger players but really you know
someone captur something you immediately
thinking about we actually spoke about
this in one of your games last week
what's that my
goodness someone captur something on
some Square you everyone immediately say
I have to capture on that square no
there are 63 other squares on the board
so if something capture on e4 you put
this position to 100 kids take 100 Kids
rating thousand most of them you 90%
immediately we'll have to capture this
because why that's where something was
captured that's what just happened to
you so no it's important to understand
because you are ridiculously strong to
see this thing right so important to
understand why it happened it happened
because there was a last capture on a
square and your brain immediately was
saying I have to capture on this
Square so what to play now
after we know we should not capture on
e4
yes you need to defend D4
no only move I can see I'm pretty
certain only move Andre King could also
see so yeah Queen C3 but not easy how to
continue and The Rook on H5 is super
annoying because
it's
preventing
F5 exchange queens and just go Rook E1
and like I don't know I don't see any
big huge problems or you could have
exchanged queens
before but here tomaseski played this
Rook
E1 and got in trouble
here
take first of all can you take the queen
not really right because
check and check and just taking
everything that's
finished and now Ben spoke tiny bit
about
Retreats white has one excellent
move mik is going to suffer some
material losses here well a pawn if I
remember Okay computer was saying Queen
B1 and was saying somewhat unclear well
white is better of course but half a
point or something not not that dramatic
but this is the move
that tomaseski didn't see 100% 100% And
tomaseski that few minutes ago let's
see has 8 minutes time advantage that's
a lot I mean it's 100% right he has
twice his opponent time pretty much it's
it's going and shrinking shrinking
shrinking and this is where you can see
is in trouble 2 minutes extra on the
clock down on the clock big
time and playing this
fast still they're playing fast so it's
in
discontinuation but just really bad
position here
Queen D7 the problem is that his King is
weak and White's plan is just to go G5
Bishop
H5 really no no not not that easy to
defend this
one not that easy to defend this
one Queen C2 I think he played que well
could he have taken here maybe maybe no
because just this
move just this move and this like really
not is easy to see how to protect
anything yeah just just really very
straightforward
idea okay probably probably about losing
here okay just to see that you are not
sleeping and we will finish this one
what after Queen E6 what is white going
to
play because if if this is working then
black is
Happy Bishop take it s and the queen is
not protected so he played King G7 what
what this idea after Bishop
take beautiful so now we finish super
basic kit tactics we can
continue take so what is this threat
now actually I was serious what is this
threat
now he want to win the game pretty much
on the
spot Queen H6 Queen H6 yeah and after
this one once again we're going to
play Rook F7 okay excellent so we see
all the cheap
tactics Queen 87 is losing there was
some way somehow to survive I don't even
maybe King G8 was the move I don't even
remember but take attacking
everything does
it oh oh that that's just the broadcast
compared to the official time no
here and resign Rook h8 is being
threatened and of course this resulting
with Rook G3 so and King really was not
at any point worse in the game I mean at
some point it looked like he has nothing
or maybe kind yeah maybe at some point
it looked like optically black was a bit
a bit more comfortable but black should
have taken a
draw I'm not certain right tomasheski
did maybe again the less time control
the faster the game andri is is a
favorite and maybe tomaseski thought
that he can do something here but well
once again this is how andrein style is
not risking that much he plays really
solid no but but very very good for
matches it's incredible and you know and
when when there some possibili open is
just there and not giving many many
chances so you know we have Kik that you
know you can say whatever you want but
it's probably very difficult to be one
of the favorites and actually from some
round for the last few rounds he is the
favorite pretty much okay maybe kaana
but I still think people were thinking
Kik is the favorite and just making it
all the way Aran was knocked out long
ago um kakin was really actually andrein
beat karakin same style right two draws
and he beat him in the rapid player
number five six in the world karaki is
out guki is
out um many many out Nakamura is out Kik
is there made it to the final you know
it's I I think well good for him playing
against Andre kin that's really a big
surprise well I guess I guess kamell is
a big favorite especially since there
are four games I mean if you will put
eight games or 12 games I think I think
everyone will say kamnik is a huge
favorite the more games nobody has a
doubt he's a better player four games is
not two
and I think kamnik is the big favorite
but for andrein definitely the most
impressive Tournament of his life and we
rest day tomorrow and
Friday starting to play
again
yeah